Welcome students to the
Pharmacology
of Antibiotics.
The Aminoglycosides
is the topic of this
lecture in our series.
Dr. Goldstein speaking.
Please don't be afraid
to contact me if you
feel like you need
help with pharmacology
and you can
come by yourself
or bring your friends.
We can do a Zoom or
in-person meeting.
Select the learning
objectives, mechanisms,
mechanisms,
mechanisms, as always,
because mechanisms
form the
foundation of
your knowledge as
a student and
as a physician.
I'm inviting you also
to apply your knowledge.
Preparation
materials and links.
This group of drugs,
the aminoglycosides in
the following lecture,
the protein synthesis
inhibitors, targets
are in the bacterial
ribosome. These are
two figures showing the
bacterial ribosome. On
the left, it's what it
more or less looks like,
and the features of
it, the action points
have been colored in.
And on the right
-hand side is a figure
representing the
bacterial ribosome.
We're going to be
talking about the
protein synthesis
process. The sites
are the A site
where this tRNA with
the attached amino
acid will settle to
start the process
and move it along.
And I'll go into
more detail when we
get to that point. The
drugs are indicated
here by the letters.
These are the
points at which they
have their binding
sites, I've added
the amino glycosides
here. We'll talk
more about that.
Protein synthesis,
and this is your
key points that I'm
not going to read
you these slides.
They're here for
your overview if
you wish. You can
use them for a
summary. You can
use them to learn
all you need to
know if you wish.
Watching the videos,
watching the video
lectures is completely
optional. If you would
rather get the new
learning from a
different resource,
please by all means do so.
Definitions here.
The bacterial ribosome
is made up of two
components, the 30s
and the 50s. The S is
a sedimentation rate
that indicates the
mass of these different
features in the
ribosome, 30S being
smaller than the 50S.
It's made up of RNA
and it translates the
mRNA into protein. So
that's the machinery.
Within the ribosomes we
have our 16S
ribosomal RNA,
which is on the
30S ribosome, and
that's the A site,
the attachment
site. And we have
our 23S ribosomal
RNA on the 50S
ribosome, and
that's the peptidyl
transferase site.
Those are the main
definitions that
you're going to
need to know in
order to understand
the protein
synthesis process
and inhibiting it.
More key points for you.
Finally, this one.
I put here the
spectinomycin.
It's part of the protein
synthesis inhibitors.
It's rarely used.
It's not even
available in the
United States, but it
could still appear
on a board exam,
so I want to make
you aware of it.
I'm not going to be
talking about it.
Here are the steps
in the bacterial
protein synthesis
process, pretty much the
same as any protein
synthesis process.
Bacterial ribosome
is different, is
structurally
different, different in
size also, than
our human mammalian
eukaryotic protein
synthesis machinery.
It is a 70S ribosome.
That's what this whole
business is called.
The two together, 70S,
made up of the 30S that I
mentioned before,
and the 50S.
Within it are the
sites in which
the proteins
are synthesized.
To repeat, here
is the transfer
RNA, tRNA bringing
in the amino
acid and it will
settle right here
in the A site,
the acceptor site.
We see the amino
acid sitting right
here. a bond will form
with the amino acid
that's next to it
as the tRNA moves
over to the peptidyl
transferase site so
we get that bond
formation and the
protein lengthens and
it's here in the so
-called exit tunnel
imagine this is a
little tunnel the
proteins are coming out
and here we have the
cytoplasm coming out
into the cytoplasm of
the bacterial cell.
Then when that bond
has been formed and
the tRNA now loses
that amino acid, it
moves off and out. And
then another one will
come back in and
dot, dot, dot, on and
on until the protein
is finished. And
there's a codon that
will indicate finish.
We're not going
to go into that.
Sites here,
tetracycline and the
aminoglycosides
are here at the so
-called A site,
the 16S ribosomal
RNA. The difference
between them,
well, the main
difference is their
actual mechanism of
action. Also, the
aminoglycosides
are irreversible.
They bind irreversibly.
All of the other
protein synthesis
inhibitors bind reversibly.
The other protein
synthesis inhibitors
have sites of
action in the 50S
ribosome. We'll
get to that in more
detail when we get
to those drugs.
The starred drugs
are the ones that you
need to know by name.
These are frequently
used, important
drugs, and each one of
them can appear on a
board exam by name.
Gentamycin, Tobramycin,
Amikacin,
Streptomycin,
Neomycin.
Plazomycin is
a more recent
addition to the group.
Peromamycin has been
around a long time.
We'll talk more
about this when
we get to the
parasitic drugs.
They all work
basically the same.
They are amino
sugars. I put a
picture of an amino
sugar up here.
They are connected
by glycosidic bonds.
They are highly polar
cations, water soluble.
They're more active
in alkaline pH than
in acid pH, so their
efficacy in an acidic
environment is somewhat
lower than in
an alkaline pH.
Irreversible, I mentioned
that before. They
are bactericidal. This
is another difference
with the other
protein synthesis
inhibitors, which are
largely bacteriostatic.
What are they used
for? Well, they're
active against aerobic
gram-negative organisms.
This is what we see
their major use,
major use.
Aerobic gram
-negative organisms.
Thinking what should
be popping into
your head mainly
here would be
the gut bugs, the
enterobacteriales.
They're also
active against
aerobic gram
-positive bacteria,
streptococci, enterococci,
staphylococci.
Now there's a little
bit of information here
you need to appreciate
that, and that is that
the gram-positive
have a thick cell wall
and the gram-negative
have a thin cell wall.
Well,
the aminoglycosides
have to get through
this thick cell
wall. Remember, it's
a nice matrix in order
to get to the site
of action inside
the bacterial cell.
And when given together
with a cell wall
inhibitor, and what
should be jumping to
your mind here, beta
-lactams especially,
the beta-lactams
now break down that
cell wall and the
aminoglycosides
reach the site
of action in high
enough concentrations
to be effective.
The aminoglycosides
properties are all related
really to that that
amino glycoside water
soluble polar structure
water soluble and
polar at physiologic
pH naturally so they're
given IV IM or
intrathecally they are not
absorbed from the GI
tract they are polar
they can also be used
topically they can be
put in ophthalmic drops
So think not oral.
They distribute an
extracellular fluid
because of their water
solubility. So imagine
if your patient has
extra extracellular
fluid because of edema
or fluid overload.
That's going to affect
the volume of distribution
which is going to
affect the dosing.
Poor ***********
into tissues that
are inflamed.
This is low pH and
more acidic pH and
inflamed tissues.
Tissues that have
low oxygen because
they have they
require oxygen which
we'll talk about for
their distribution
into the site of
action and they
have poor ***********
into the CSF.
And in the rare
cases that it's
necessary, they can
be given intrathecally
right into the
spinal fluid.
Patients who have
meningitis, if we're
treating them for
meningitis, recall
that they have
leakier blood-brain
barrier because of
the inflammation.
And therefore,
an intravenous
administration
will achieve the
levels that are
needed in the CSF.
So,
intrasecal CNS, but we
don't do that
for neonates.
For one thing, they
have leakier blood
-brain barriers
anyway because
they're immature.
High concentrations
accumulate in renal
tubular cells and
endolymph and
perilymph of the ear.
Accumulate in kidney
cells and ear cells.
Think toxicities here.
They cross the
placenta. Think
about potential
fetotoxicity.
They're rapidly
eliminated by glomerular
filtration. They're
that tiny, soluble
molecule that
dissolves in the plasma
and follows and is
excreted through the
glomeruli along with
the plasma. plasma.
Half-life is only about
two to three
hours usually.
Ah, but imagine
people who have
significant
renal impairment
can be as long
as two days.
So it's very important
to adjust dosage in
patients who have
renal impairment. And
patients who receive
these These
aminoglycosides are
normally very ill, and
their renal function
is possibly fine
when they start, but
remembering the
nephrotoxicity of these
drugs, the renal
function can drop.
So this has to be
monitored so that
the drugs can be
dosed properly,
and they have
significant toxicity.
Aminoglycosides are
cleared by the kidney.
Clearance is directly
proportional to
serum creatinine.
I'm sure you remember
that from pharmacokinetic
selectors.
Therefore, rapid
changes in renal
function can occur
in the critically
ill, which is
patients who get these
drugs, patients
with acute kidney
injury, septic
shock, major surgery.
Therefore we need to
monitor. So what are
we going to monitor?
Serum creatinine
because of the
relationship to clearance.
Follow me?
Any questions?
Okay the pharmacokinetic
pharmacodynamic
profile. It is
concentration
dependent, the maximal
concentration or
peak to the MIC ratio,
and this indicates
that the higher the
drug concentration,
that's what this
symbol means,
the faster the rate
and the greater
the extent of
bacterial killing,
concentration
-dependent killing.
Aminoglycosides also
have a significant post
-antibiotic effect,
where suppression of
bacterial growth
persists beyond the time
during which measurable
drug is present. In
other words, when it
falls below the MIC.
This is why, even
though it's got such a
short half-life, two
to three hours, it can
be given once a day
for most indications.
It also is associated,
the efficacy is
associated with the
24-hour area under the
concentration versus time
curve to the MIC ratio.
Within the literature
for all of these
antibiotics that
we're talking about,
goals have been
defined. And since we're
talking about gram
-negative bacilli as
being what these drugs
are mainly used for,
these have been defined.
So what does all of this
mean? It means dosing.
The dose that
is associated
with clinical
effect, which is
based on the AUC
to MIC ratio.
A little picture
to help remind you.
We have our peak,
concentration,
area under the
concentration versus time
curve is indicated
with these lines.
Here's our
minimum inhibitory
concentration and
time, over time.
So it's drug administration,
area under the
concentration versus
time curve. Now, some
few cases will use
the original so-called
low-dose aminoglycoside
dosing strategy,
which is the same total
amount of dose in the
24-hour period, but
it's divided, it's given
every eight hours,
the frequency of every
eight hours. So the
peaks are going to be
lower because it's the
lower dose for each,
it's the lower
amount of drug being
given for each dose,
drops off, we see
it stays, really
stays above the MIC
for the grant
majority of the time.
Give another dose,
falls off, give another
dose, falls off.
So, for monitoring,
the blood levels are
going to be measured
right before the
next dose is given,
trough levels.
Mechanism now.
Aminoglycosides
passively diffuse across
porin channels in
the outer membrane.
So, we're obviously
talking about gram
-negative bacteria. then
are actively transported
across the cell
membrane to the
cytoplasm by an oxygen
-dependent mechanism.
Oxygen-dependent
aerobic organisms.
Because aerobic
organisms are using
that oxygen
-dependent mechanism.
Anaerobic organisms
are not using oxygen.
Well, once inside,
they bind to
the 16S ribosomal
RNA on the 30S
ribosome, and they
appear to have at
least three
separate mechanisms.
They block the formation
of the initiation
complex, which is
indicated here.
they cause miscoding
so they they misread
the message on the
mRNA and as a result
the wrong amino acid
gets incorporated
so that's indicated
here and they prevent
it from moving along
the translocation
of the tRNA movement
along the mRNA.
So those three
mechanisms have
been observed
experimentally.
Now other things
may be happening.
Maybe these wrong
proteins, because the
amino acids, wrong
amino acids have been
inserted, might be
causing some damage, and
a formation of a
monosome. So these amino
glycosides are binding
to bacterial polysomes.
I'll talk about that
on the next slide.
Polysomes are several
ribosomes strung
out along the mRNA
strand and this is
typical of bacterial
protein synthesis.
These dots here are
indicated indicating
the ribosomes and
all these little
strands coming
out those are the
proteins in various
lengths and phases.
So if one of the
things the amino
glycosides does is
the formation of
this single monosome,
then the bacteria
is not properly
making its proteins.
Here's a drawing
to help you
visualize better
what you're seeing
in the electron
micrograph.
Spectrum of activity,
I've referred to this
a couple of times
now, aerobic gram
-negative bacilli, so
the enterobacteriales,
and pseudomonas,
pseudomonas aeruginosa,
which is an aerobic
gram-negative bacterium
that's not enteric,
and the aerobic gram
-positive streptococcus,
Staphylococcus
enterococcus, as I
mentioned, and I wrote
it out here, poorly
********* intact thick
peptidoglycan cell
wall and clinically are
not reliably effective
when used alone.
Aminoglycosides are
almost always used
with another drug,
certainly for
treatment of the gram
-positive infections
and frequently,
almost always, for the
treatment of gram
-negative infections.
So what is
intrinsically resistant?
Well, anaerobic bacteria,
right? They're not
using an oxygen
-dependent system.
They're not
metabolizing
oxygen. Facultative
anaerobes in an
anaerobic environment,
anaerobic, anaerobic.
Acquired
resistance. This is
certainly of
importance because
of the big
resistance problem.
Inactivation by
production of
transferases. This is
the main mechanism.
Transferases that
inactivate the drug,
they will transfer
another group onto the
drug which will
inactivate it by
phosphorylation,
adenylation, and acetylation.
organisms that prevent
its entry or pump
it out so impaired
accumulation within the
organism an oxygen
dependent transport
system that doesn't
bring the amino
glycoside in or target
alteration this is
mainly seen with
streptomycin in the
treatment of mycobacterium
tuberculosis.
Cross resistance
can occur,
but is unpredictable.
Susceptibility tests
will guide therapy. What
do we use them for?
Serious infections.
That's it.
They are quite toxic.
So empirically,
aerobic, gram-negative
bacilli, along with
other antibiotics.
Gentamicin and
tobramycin are
the first two,
mainly gentamicin.
Amikacin is good when
there's resistance.
Always used in combination
with antibiotics
from another class
to broaden the
spectrum. There is
one exception to that.
Infective endocarditis.
This is a gram
-positive infection.
The aminoglycosides are
used together with
a cell wall active
drug, penicillin,
ampicillin, ceftriaxone,
and possibly vancomycin
if the person can't
get one of these
beta-lactams because
these drugs will break
down the cell wall,
increase the uptake
of aminoglycosides,
in addition to
the fact that
aminoglycosides
together with the cell
wall inhibitor
have a synergistic
effect. So uptake
and synergy.
Uptake and synergy for
infective endocarditis,
which is a gram
-positive infection that
can be caused by any
of these organisms.
Directed therapy.
So we know what the
infective organism is,
and we know what the
susceptibility of
that organism is to
the various potential
antibiotic therapies
that could be used.
When established, the
antibiotic therapy
should be changed to a
less toxic antibiotic
if appropriate. So
now, let's say we have
the aminoglycoside on
board together with
other drugs for empiric
therapy. We find
out what the organism
is sensitive to and
switch it over to a
less toxic antibiotic.
If the
aminoglycoside is the
most appropriate
therapy, then
of course we
stick with that.
Prolonged aminoglycosides
is limited
to life-threatening
infections
unresponsive to
less toxic agents.
That's the
takeaway with the
therapeutic uses
of aminoglycosides.
Aerobic gram
-negative bacilli,
aerobic gram-positives,
short duration of
therapy, switch to
directed therapy
when appropriate. So
let's talk about
these different
drugs within the
aminoglycosides
group. How do
they compare?
When do you use one
and not the other?
Gentamicin and
tobramycin are
pretty much the
same, really.
Tobamycin seems to have
slightly more activity
against Pseudomonas
aeruginosa, and
you're likely to see
it used more frequently
when you are in your
clinical environment.
for patients who have
pseudomonas aeruginosa.
Gentamicin seems to
be more active against
the gut bugs, the
enterobacteriales, and
you'll see that most
often used for the
aerobic gram-negative
non-pseudomonas
infections. Will gentamicin
work for a pseudomonas
infection? Yes.
Will tobramycin work
for an enterobacterialis
infection? Yes.
Gentamycin is the one
that's used for the
synergistic combination
for the treatment
of infective
endocarditis caused by
enterococcus faecalis
or enterococcus
faecium. And this is
the situation when it's
given every hours
instead of once a day.
It is known to be
efficacious that way.
Zoonoses.
So these arthropod
usually arthropod
transmitted infections.
Tularemia which
is also known as
rabbit fever and
has other names and
plague. Bubonic
plague. Black plague.
Plague is is one of
those that I think
you're going to
want to remember
because of its
historical significance.
Tobermycin is available
in oral inhalation
for the treatment
of Pseudomonas lung
infection in cystic
fibrosis patients
who are at risk for
getting these. It would
be the preferred
inhaled type for
pseudomonas lung
infection. It produces a
high concentration of
drug right there in
the lung where the
infection is, and
there's very little
systemic side effects
because of this route
of administration.
Amicusin now was
developed originally
because it is more
active against gentamicin
and tobramycin
-resistant infections,
gram-negative
bacterial infections,
GNB, gram
-negative bacteria.
It's also effective
for the treatment
of multidrug-resistant
tuberculosis, but
But other of the
aminoglycosides
may also be used for the
multidrug-resistant
tuberculosis.
Plazomycin, as I
mentioned, is the
most recent addition.
It doesn't have a
star on it. I think
it's important for
context that I
mention it, however.
It has only two
indications.
Complicated urinary
tract infections
that don't respond
to any other drug.
And also for the
treatment of plague.
Streptomycin has really
limited uses because
there's a great deal
of gram-negative
resistance against
it. So tularemia and
plague and multidrug
-resistant tuberculosis.
It's easy to remember,
easy to remember.
Neomycin is
only topically,
it's really toxic.
I mean, all of these
are really toxic,
given systemically,
neomycin especially.
So it's usually mixed
together with another
drug. Maybe you've heard
of neosporin, where
it mixes with another
antibiotic to broaden
the spectrum for
dermatologic infections.
it's not absorbed,
so it can
be given ******
to reduce bowel
flora prior to
bowel surgery.
And so skin, ophthalmic
drops, otic drops.
Interestingly,
hypersensitivity can frequently
occur with neomycin
-containing products,
so you get that
allergic dermatitis. so
recap gentamicin most
frequently used tobermycin
as effective slightly
better against
pseudomonas aeruginosa
gentamicin slightly better
against the gut bugs
amikacin for multi
-drug resistant
tuberculosis for gentamicin
resistant gram-negative
bacterial infections
Plazomycin also
is active against
resistant strains,
but it's only for
multidrug-resistant
UTIs caused by gram
-negative bacteria
when other drugs have
been ineffective
and also for plague.
Streptomycin has
limited use, the
zoonoses, tularemia,
and plague, and
multidrug-resistant
tuberculosis.
Neomycin, topical
only, hypersensitivity
reactions are
relatively common.
Now, I mentioned
toxicities I don't
know how many times
by now. There are
only really three
easy to remember.
Kidney toxicity,
nephrotoxicity,
ear toxicity,
ototoxicity, and
neuromuscular blockade,
which isn't a problem
for most people
but I'll talk about
when it is a problem.
Of course, there
are risk factors.
This said,
over duration of
therapy, generally
longer than five
days, so we're
not talking about
a long time,
the risk of nephrotoxicity
is very high.
Many, many patients,
even most patients,
will develop toxicity
but people who
have are of advanced
age of course have
insufficient kidney
function because
the plasma concentrations
will be higher
persistently elevated
concentrations of
drug in the plasma
which it could also be
dose related so you
have to be make sure
the dose is correct
and this is an and
therapy more than five
days and in fact the
recommendation is no
more than 48 hours
if possible previous
exposure to aminoglycosides
so maybe people
have hearing loss
because of a previous
previous exposure.
And then any other
drugs that also
cause nephrotoxicity
and ototoxicity.
So how does this happen?
Aminoglycosides
accumulate in the
proximal tubular
cells and this
they cause progressive
tubular cell
damage and glomerular
dysfunction.
They are toxic to
the host cells.
More likely with
the longer course
of therapy, more
likely with the high
dose extended
interval dosing,
sorry, more likely
with the high dose.
Notice that the
extended interval
dosing has less
nephrotoxicity.
So what does that mean?
This is the extended
interval compared to...
The reason that has
been proposed is that
during this time below,
in this time frame
in which the patient
receives no drug, the
aminoglycoside has a
chance to at least start
to leave the affected
kidney and ear cells.
Fortunately, the renal
impairment is
often reversible,
unlike the
ototoxicity, which
might not be reversible.
It can be
irreversible once
those sensory
cells are lost.
Associated with a
high-peak plasma,
duration of
aminoglycoside therapy.
This high-peak plasma
levels, this is
so confusing.
This is traditional.
This is a
traditional view.
to the, as I said in
the previous slide,
with that long time frame
before the drug
is given again,
it has a chance to
come out. But once
these hair cells are
lost, they're lost.
cochlear toxicity which
is degeneration of
the hair cells and
neurons and a person
might complain that
they have this sort of
buzzing or ringing
sound in their ears
that's a sign that
that's a symptom that
there is damage to
those hair cells and
vestibular toxicity
that's the dizziness part
And now neuromuscular
blockade.
Acute neuromuscular
blockade can cause
respiratory paralysis.
This isn't going to
occur in otherwise
healthy individuals. It
occurs in people
who already have a
neuromuscular problem,
such as myasthenia gravis,
or patients who
are receiving a
neuromuscular blocker
for surgery, for example.
What's the mechanism?
Well, it is believed
that the aminoglycosides
block a prejunctional
calcium channel.
We have here a
picture of the nerve
coming into the
skeletal muscle.
And here we have the
synapses occurring.
This is a close
-up picture on
the right side.
We have all
this neurotransmitter
in here.
and when a message
comes down the axon
it will cause
depolarization and opening
of calcium channels
and calcium will
rush in and the belief
is that by blocking
these calcium
channels, that prevents
the movement of the
vesicles containing
the neurotransmitter
from moving to
the edge and releasing
their contents.
So less neurotransmitter
means less
activation of the end
plate potential, and
that could lead to
respiratory paralysis.
streptomycin
has the other
toxicities but
also it has some
neurotoxicities and
we see that with
toxicity to the
optic nerve something
called a scotoma
which is a blind
spot and I've given
you a picture of
what that might
look like and also
peripheral neuritis
the paresthesias
The strange feeling
around the mouse,
the nervy feeling
the face, the
hands are common.
It occurs rapidly
and may persist for
several hours, but
it does go away.
Hypersensitivity
reactions,
naturally, and this
hot, tender mass
can form at the
injection site.
Cautions.
Myasthenia gravis, I
referred to that before.
This is a
neuromuscular disease.
It's an
autoimmune disease
that causes
muscle weakness.
And if these
patients already have
muscle weakness, adding
an aminoglycoside
can exacerbate
that and lead to
respiratory depression.
That's the worry.
These patients are
going to be in the
hospital. And if
they absolutely need
an aminoglycoside,
that has to be
carefully monitored,
this side effect.
Pregnancy,
congenital bilateral
deafness can occur
and has been seen,
has been reported
in the fetus.
Renal toxicity,
makes sense, doesn't
it? It's the two
major toxicities
that happen to just
about everybody
when the drug is
given long enough.
Also, in pregnancy, just
as a general statement,
their pharmacokinetic
parameters change as
the pregnancy progresses.
So, an increased
volume of distribution,
and that's going to
decrease the peak
concentration, and there
will be a shorter
half-life because of
increased clearance by
the pregnant individual.
not recommended. A lot
of these antibiotics
are not recommended
for lactation, but
the risk here is
that the babies
will take in the
antibiotic and that
will wreak havoc
with their own
intestinal flora and
lead to diarrhea.
Drug interactions.
Well, certainly
no metabolic drug
interactions because
it's not metabolized none
of them but other drugs
that are nephrotoxic
other drugs that
are ototoxic and
we've already met
vancomycin which I put
in bold because this
is something that you
should be remembering
vancomycin causes
nephrotoxicity on
its own And we talked
about vancomycin plus
an aminoglycoside,
gentamicin, for
infective endocarditis.
So nephrotoxicity
is a problem. But
infective endocarditis
must be treated.
and if this is the only
treatment vancomycin
plus an amino
glycoside then that's
what it has to be
there are other options
but you can learn
about those later
and i've listed out
several others that
i'm not asking you to
memorize now because
you haven't met those
drugs yet in our
pharmacology lectures
but you should
remember neuromuscular
blockers i did not
bold it, but you
need, I'm bolding it
now. Bold, bold, bold,
bold, bold, bold.
Because of the
neuromuscular
blocking effect.
You don't have to
remember the
names right now.
We'll get to those
at a later lecture.
But neuromuscular
blockers, bold, bold.
So in summary,
aminoglycosides
in current use are
streptomycin, gentomycin,
tobromycin, amikacin,
plasomycin, neomycin,
and peromomycin.
Amino sugars, parenteral
only for systemic
infections,
not absorbed from
the GI tract,
distributed to
extracellular fluid, renal
excreted by
glomerular filtration.
So what do we measure?
Serum creatinine to
help us keep track
of the patient's
kidney function.
They bind 16S, I
should say, RNA on
the 30S ribosome,
probable mechanism
interference with the
initiation complex,
misreading the mRNA
and incorporating
the wrong amino
acid, and inhibiting
the translocation
along the mRNA. A.
Aminoglycosides are
active against aerobic
gram-negative bacteria.
Combined with a
cell wall inhibitor,
aminoglycosides enhance
the efficacy of
aerobic gram-positive
bacterial infection,
infective endocarditis.
The most frequent
mechanism of resistance
is drug-inactivating
enzymes, acetylation,
phosphorylation,
adenylation,
which confer high
-level resistance.
There can be some
cross-sensitivity.
Amicacin and
plasomycin have
activity against
resistant organisms.
The aminoglycosides
are used in combination
with a cell wall
inhibitor to treat
the serious gram
-negative infections.
including zoonoses,
tularemia, and
plague, and infective
endocarditis.
Dentomycin, amikacin,
streptomycin
are options for the
treatment of drug
-resistant tuberculosis
in combination
with other anti
-tubercular drugs.
Amikacin and plasomycin
have activity
against the
resistant infections.
Amikacin is used
in the treatment of
various aminoglycoside
gram-negative
bacterial infections.
Plazomycin is for MDR
urinary tract
infections, complicated,
not responsive to
other antibiotics.
Gentamicin, tobramycin,
neomycin are all
available in topical
formulations, DERMS,
ophthalmic, odic.
Neomycin is
topical only, used
with others,
other antibiotics.
All are nephrotoxic
and ototoxic.
Risk factors are
more than five days
of use, remembering
that we generally
recommend no more
than 48 hours.
So renal insufficiency,
older age, other
nephrotoxic and
ototoxic drugs can make
it worse. At high
doses, aminoglycosides
can produce this
neuromuscular blockade
and that's referred
to as curare-like
neuromuscular blockade
because it's like
curare and curare is
a natural substance
obtained from plants
and it was used by
Amazonian natives to
stop their prey from
running away. You
put it on the darts.
And that concludes
this lecture.
Thank you for listening.